Howie Mandel is all about comic relief
but with an ongoing pandemic and all the
civil unrest how he admitted to me he's
feeling overwhelmed I'm not doing great
I feel a little broken I feel you know I
think we're better than this some of my
kids live in Santa Monica so my son was
up on the roof live-streaming all night
love yeah we got a change yeah we do
there aren't any words I'm just sad and
the one word that comes to mind is hope
you know and I think that's what maybe
AGT gives us it's true AGT may be a
talent competition but at its core it's
about hope opportunities and making
dreams come true do you have four yeses
tonight's show was taped before
coronavirus forced changes in the
production so producers aren't sure yet
what the show will look like by the end
of July but Simon told us even though
it's been a challenge the show must go
on when we first started we had a full
audience and then day by day you know
things started to get worse so we went
nine days with an audience and then we
have to do two days without an audience
which we've never done before and then
by day 11 we just went okay it's it
really really isn't safe now this week
you have a comedian who goes after Simon
I was like what's his name she's like
Alejandro I'm like no you couldn't do
assignment
there's only four you choose the one to
slam Simon the bus I mean that's a bold
move
hi here's what I love most of all this
entire interview you have is that a
coloring book the baby sharks coloring
book right there you can see this this
is the room that the grandkids come over
if I didn't have grandchildren
this would just be a little creepy that
I have these days but these are these
are my grandchildren Powys grandkids are
social distancing from their granddad
right now but in these tough times
Howe and his wife Terry are a sweet
reminder of how a little humor and a lot
of love can go a long way
congratulations just had a wedding
anniversary 40 years Wow how was that
while you're in court I thought it was
great my wife isn't for me now of what
is this third month of lockdown that
maybe there might not be a 41 I'm
annoying to live with you know I said
let's redo our vows her redone bow is
enough already so now I just feel like
the luckiest guy in the world
[Music]